on va se veulent d'augmenter leurs jours
devant nous
à noter que pas compris préparez-vous à
rentrer dans l'histoire à fulda on va se
parler on en est sécurisé c'est quoi ta
vie de watergate patriotes bois terrain
guillaume voilà ça fait qu'un guignol
ok on est peut-être encore fait des
étincelles je suis comme un diesel au
monde j'ai pas aimé prendre une bastos
mois et la mission mais on est 30 avoir
la même
il ya bien un premier de la classe qui
va sortir de leurs gongs messieurs dames
de résistance qui causent soupçonne
l'existence et la secrétaire
une haie lors de bals masqués saputo
coup j'ai déjà pratiqué notre mental ça
c'est bien mais ce n'est simple bush au
moins que mon vote c'est marrant j'ai
l'impression que les choses changent
des jeunes moi pas tu ne râle croyez
vraiment qu'on peut gagner la guerre
avec ces incapables ya deux pintes de
destin un destin horizontale à risque
d'incertitude
[Musique]
oui
je dois bien reconnaître que je suis
impressionné